and tickets officially purchased for
Halloween ends
I'll have John react to it on peacock
for not being here this morning guys
Halloween ends final trailer I'm excited
for this man super duper excited I went
to Halloween Horror Nights uh just the
other day and out of all the mazes the
the common consensus amongst the whole
group was at the Halloween maze was
actually the best one it's just got me
in a super duper Michael Myers mood so
if you're here please go ahead leave a
like
let's see what's going on in this
trailer and talk about it
Without a Trace
hello
oh [ __ ]
foreign
in that cave this whole time
watching me you know he was you pretend
like you moved on but you're actually
just obsessed with death
what are you gonna do when Michael comes
back for you
because he is coming
but this time
something feels different
he's more dangerous God damn right he is
foreign
kill him
get me
evil dies tonight
foreign
maybe the only way he can die is if I
die too
it all ends now
oh man
holding his mask in the street
it's got to be the fake Michael right
you came here
or not never mind okay
it looked like that was from the same
scene because there was that theory
going around that in the trailer that
the previous one that that was a fake
Michael Myers but that looks like it was
from the same scene unless it's just
another bulky ass impersonator of
Michael Myers going around town all
right we got ourselves another another
solid ass trailer for Halloween ends
despite what anyone says about Halloween
kills I know that there's a divide when
it comes to that movie Evil dies
tonight's just one of the greatest
quotes of all time I don't care what
anyone says I've been saying evil dies
tonight for about a year now ever since
I saw that film just once a day I gotta
say it it's usually part of my Mantra
before I go to bed dude the marketing
here alongside with what Jamie Lee
Curtis has been talking about in
interviews it really seems like they're
putting their heart and soul into this
project I have faith feel like they're
gonna deliver on this one like I like
this setup quite a bit to have the
Halloween kills be in like seconds after
Halloween and then for this one to be
four years later adds a bit of a
realistic touch to it Michael Myers you
know he got this [ __ ] kicked out of him
even though he came out on top because
Michael Myers always gets back up even
though he got the [ __ ] kicked out of him
at the end of uh the last one you know
the guy he sustained some injuries looks
like he hasn't washed since then imagine
that after four years you do gotta heal
up and he doesn't strike me as a kind of
individual who's you know gonna pay out
of pocket at an ER visit that he's
probably just gonna naturally heal from
all the wounds he's had to deal with but
it's I imagine that it's also created
this like Brewing simmering rage within
him there's something that feels very
personal about it again and I think
that's what made the Halloween 2018
reboot work so well how personal it felt
especially for Laurie Strode you know
when I hear and Jamie Lee Curtis talking
about saying goodbye
for like the third time with this
franchise she gets very emotional about
it seemingly Curtis is just a goddamn
gem years like over 40 years with this
franchise and to me like turning in her
best work in this franchise with
Halloween 2018 and it looks like that
performance gonna be carrying over into
here and you know when you start getting
like really emotional in interviews
there's one where I felt like she
started like tear up as she was talking
about it it's pretty gnarly you know you
don't really say that about too many
horror franchises and her performance in
2018 is one of my all-time favorite
horror movie performances and especially
out of the slasher genre and her
performance there is so captivating and
that was something that was sort of
missing for Halloween kills for me the
strong Spotlight on Laurie Strode this
is bringing it full circle to that not
only bringing it full circle to the this
recent trilogy but also to the original
Hollywood film as well I mean that makes
sense considering the fact that the 2018
Halloween is supposed to be the the real
part two this movie in particular you
know we're hearing a lot of crazy things
about it that you know even Jamie Lee
Curtis is saying like this movie's gonna
push some buttons and that it might
upset some people you know I I know
Halloween kills uh Dove a little bit
more into the social commentary side I
hear this will deal with the pandemic
and in some way I don't know I don't I
really when I hear over here I'm like I
don't know what they're going to be
doing that's really going to upset
audiences what I'm finding so striking
about these trailers because while I
like this one quite a bit especially
with with the death of the guy in the
pool and then you know the classic
stabbing them and they're on the wall
you that felt just such like a fun
slasher movie but the the especially
Halloween kills did not feel like a fun
slasher movie that was like it it had a
bit of that like Rob Zombie grit to it
where it's really disturbing and
unsettling violence and that felt like
fun violence but I also imagine there's
going to be some of that like oh this is
uncomfortable violent as well in this
movie as you see that that brutality
that I'm speaking about this feels very
character driven at the same time poor
Lori strodden the way they talk about it
is she going to die in this movie it
seems like they would kill a like this
trailer dropping too many hints that
should she die especially having lines
in this trailer like maybe for him to
die I have to die like we're tethered
that way so in order to in order for
evil to die tonight I have to die along
with the evil maybe uh I just hope that
you know she she isn't in her older
years now and as as athletic as as
athletic as she has remained this entire
time and as strong as a performer she
has remained I imagine that she would
want to really say finally be able to
say goodbye in a proper fashion if it's
the end for her would that really be the
end for Michael Myers you doubt it I
don't know I'm kind of having like a
stream of Consciousness Thoughts with
them without having this room of
Consciousness thoughts right now with
Halloween ends I'm liking thematically
what this this is putting on display
like you feel the fear you feel the rage
I've been hearing a lot of talk about
from the test screenings at least like a
common thing that's been going around is
that the finale of this movie is very
very intense and that was something I
said about the 2018 one was that finale
was really gripping and suspenseful and
in and if that's going to be the case
for this one that's great news
especially when it's supposed to be the
end of a particular Trilogy if you can
go out with a bang I hope that they are
actually able to pull this off but this
one seems like it's definitely bringing
it back a little bit more to the 2018
version because
you know so much of what I feel like
this Trilogy has dealt with is is grief
you know especially when it comes to
Lori Strode but even the town of
Haddonfield this is a big story about
grief it's a big story about grief
essentially and the the moment that they
show in the trailer here with Allison
where they're butting heads with each
other you know I imagine that they're
dealing with The Grieving the loss of
Lori shorts daughter Karen created a
strain within their own relationship as
well like all they have is each other
they got to protect each other but
perhaps there's some blame going around
as well it's got to do a lot this movie
it's got to be a conclusion it's got to
be the Final Chapter it's got to keep
the character moments going it's got to
have that nuance and it's got to have
some exciting kills it's got to be
brutal there's a there's a lot this film
actually has to pull off at the end of
the day I think all of us really want to
just have a good time more than anything
else anyway guys thanks so much for
being here see you guys soon
foreign